[Música]
viajar es el mejor antídoto contra los
prejuicios contra la intolerancia contra
la estrechez mental es una cita de mark
twain
y coherente con su pensamiento que hizo
realizar un viaje insólito quiso viajar
al pasado un yanqui del siglo 19 se
trasladó al pasado al siglo sexto para
visitar la inglaterra del rey arturo
poco tiempo después en el siglo 19 hg
wells escribe un relato fantástico
su protagonista construye una máquina
que le permite sin moverse de su casa
viajar hacia un futuro muy lejano muy
incierto son dos historias inverosímiles
pero que marcan un sueño viajar en el
tiempo dos historias imposibles e
impensables de realizar en el momento en
que fueron escritas pero que pensamos
hoy día será posible cuando estamos
entrando en el siglo 21 ya bien entrado
será posible algún día poder viajar en
el tiempo poder desplazarnos al futuro
poder pasear por el pasado o son
simplemente ideas que debemos archivar
en la carpeta de los deseos y
realizables
los sueños imposibles comienzan en un
principio y se manifiestan como mitos
pero después con el tiempo la literatura
el arte le van dando forma los hacen
viables a base de una gran imaginación
conscientes o no somos viajeros en el
tiempo solo que la velocidad a la que
hacemos ese viaje es absolutamente
estricta en un sentido único a razón de
un segundo cada segundo de una hora cada
hora
pero sería posible acelerar y movernos a
razón de un día por segundo de una
semana por segundo y viajar de esta
manera y dejar atrás el presente un
sueño imposible parece una realidad que
no se podrá o que no se puede realizar
pero como dije los sueños que empiezan
como mitos se van transformando con la
imaginación se pueden hacer posible pero
todo empezó a cambiar a partir del siglo
17 cuando surge una nueva forma de
pensar una forma de pensar sobre el
mundo real se llama ciencia y su
objetivo es entender todo lo que nos
rodea y lo que nos rodea es básicamente
espacio y tiempo no es de señal por lo
tanto que los primeros sueños
irrealizables se dirigieran a conseguir
su conquista a poder viajar por el
tiempo a poder viajar por el espacio
desde muy pronto
surgieron en los primeros mitos la
necesidad de viajar
a través alcanzando cielo y el primer
objetivo el primer la primera estación
en ese viaje sería llegar a la luna
y escritores como diciendo de samósata
como cyrano de bergerac allan poe y
otras muchas mentes imaginativa
desarrollaron los métodos más imposibles
y más extravagantes para conseguir el
objetivo de manera que grandes barcos
impulsados por tremendas solas o
bandadas de aves alimentaban
instrumentos y estructuras frágiles o
simplemente plantas en un crecimiento de
pensado por jenna cercano al objetivo
pero en definitiva solamente eran
imaginación hacía falta un gran golpe de
genio un golpe de genio científico para
que todo empezara a cambiar
newton relacionados dos hechos
aparentemente inconexos la caída del
fruto maduro de un manzano y el
movimiento de los planetas alrededor del
sol
una idea
su curso que tenían la misma causa la
acción de la gravedad una idea
revolucionaria una idea distinta nueva
muy difícil de entender en ese tiempo
hacía falta una gran dosis de
explicación para poder hacerla llegar a
todos y youtube religión para ello este
dibujo es un dibujo extraordinario
sencillo profundo a la vez el diagrama
se explica por sí solo
si subimos a un acantilado y dejamos
caer un objeto este seguirá un camino
vertical hacia el suelo pero si le damos
un empujón horizontal
el objeto caerá por su peso algo más
lejos y algo más lejos caerá si el
empujón que le damos es aún mayor
hasta ahí nada extraordinario todo
normal
todo forma parte de nuestra experiencia
pero newton da un paso más y va más allá
de la experiencia e imagina entonces un
empujón enorme de forma y manera que al
ser un crítico el objeto cae y cae y
sigue cayendo y cae permanentemente
newton ha puesto ese objeto en órbita
y si es da un empujón aún mayor
conseguirá sacarlo de la tierra con este
dibujo newton nos enseña cómo se
abandona la tierra cómo se llega a la
luna como se viaja por el espacio
poco tiempo después julio verne
la literatura de nuevo
intenta cumplir el sueño de u2 y ac y
sigue sus leyes pero le falta algo
fundamental la tecnología es necesaria
para darle ese gran empujón solamente
puede usar lo que tiene más a mano un
enorme cañón que por cierto hubiera
destrozado a los tripulantes justamente
en el momento de la salida
las mías
secuencial se completa el día 4 de
octubre de 1957 ese día ese dibujo salto
del papel a la realidad ese día fuimos
capaces de poner en órbita el satélite
sputnik y unos años después en julio del
69 por fin pisamos la luna las líneas
secuencial
de la conquista del espacio es clara
mitos literatura ciencia tecnología
realización la pregunta es seguirá la
misma secuencia que hemos argumentado
aquí los viajes en el tiempo o por el
contrario el tiempo es algo muy distinto
mirar 2001 odisea del espacio
fue una película que el primer momento
clave y la vitola cuántas veces
me llamó precisamente a de ello dos
escenas dos escenas que en su conjunto
son una capacidad de síntesis o
expresiones y extraordinarias para ver
leer comportamientos humanos a lo largo
del proceso evolutivo en la primera de
las escenas unos sonidos se acercan o se
topan con una estructura geométrica
perfecta un monolito
y se acercan a él manifestando sus
temores y necesitando su curiosidad
quieren tocarlo quieren aprenderlo y en
un salto elíptico en el tiempo como
ninguna otra historia del cine milenios
después se afectan al monolito unos
astronautas
que no encuentran y lo curioso y lo
extraordinario es que realizan los
mismos gestos se mueven con los mismos
movimientos hermanitos
las dudas las ansias de saber y de
comprender son absolutamente
intemporales baste este ejemplo como
similitudes entre la historia contada de
los viajes en el espacio y la posible
que podemos esperar de los viajes en el
tiempo
año de 1905 un joven y absolutamente
desconocido albert eisntein de sólo 26
años de edad absolutamente ajeno en los
artículos científicos y académicos del
momento
viene a subvertir todas las ideas y las
concepciones que tenemos sobre el
espacio y el tiempo con su thriller de
la vida decía se subvierte todo lo que a
sentido común tenía que decir sobre el
tiempo y la teoría se sustenta o se basa
en dos postulados bien sencillo es decir
la velocidad de la luz es constante es
invariable una velocidad enorme
trescientos mil kilómetros por segundo
siete vueltas y media la tierra en un
solo segundo y además constituye una
barrera insalvable nada puede ir en el
universo más rápido que la luz es todo
postulado derrumban de una manera
definitiva el concepto viene sentado de
tiempo absoluto y como ocurrió lo que
hemos contado con respecto al hito
vuelve a repetirse de nuevo una idea
novedosa revolucionaria que requiere una
explicación sencilla para poder ser
asimilada y einstein para hacerlo
crea este maravilloso experimento mental
un reloj de luz un reloj de luz que
funciona mediante dos espejos paralelos
entre los cuales se mueve continuamente
un pulso lumínico esteros tan preciso su
tic tac están marcando cada una de las
interacciones del pulso lumínico con los
espejos y la ecuación para resolverlo es
bien sencilla solamente hay que recordar
aquella que fue quizá la primera que nos
enseñaron en física del mini depurador
docente espacio es igual a velocidad por
tiempo y el tiempo que mire tanto un
observador que está dentro del reloj
como alguien que está fuera es el mismo
son tiempos idénticos pero si ahora
movemos el reloj de luz en forma
horizontal
para la persona que está dentro del rol
de luz nada ha cambiado las medidas que
realiza el tiempo son exactamente
idénticas al caso anterior pero qué
ocurre para alguien que permanece fuera
en reposo ahora la distancia que
recorrió la luz es mayor que antes pero
dada la invariabilidad de la velocidad
de la luz dada su constancia
necesariamente ha tenido que variar su
percepción del tiempo y para resolverlo
unas matemáticas muy sencillas la
geometría del triángulo de pitágoras
pone
el encantamiento a nuestra disposición
los segundos que emite la persona que
está en movimiento son más largos que
los segundos que mide la persona que
está en reposo el movimiento ha dilatado
el tiempo el tiempo deja de ser absoluto
ahora es un tiempo relativo las horas no
son igual de largas para el observador
que está en movimiento que para el
observador que está en reposo
a las velocidades en que no vemos el
efecto es absolutamente inapreciable
incluso al 70% de la verdadera luz en
los viajes los efectos no serían
claramente palpables pero si nos
viéramos a velocidades próximas a la
velocidad de la luz entonces aseguró los
efectos serían sorprendentes
imaginad que alguien aquí alguien en la
sala que tenga 35 años ahora mismo esta
noche inicia un viaje un viaje de cinco
años en una nave que lo va a llevar a
una velocidad del 90 y 95 por ciento de
la velocidad de la luz eso sí quiere a
la vuelta celebrar un cumpleaños muy
rotundo 40 años un número redondo y para
ello deja invitaciones a sus amistades
para celebrar una fiesta a la vuelta
cuando vuelve y se encuentra en la
fiesta a sus amigos estos han envejecido
50 años
si pudiéramos ir aún más lejos y aún más
rápido al 99 995 por ciento de la
velocidad de la luz y saliéramos mañana
en una nave a esa velocidad para hacer
un viaje a una estrella a la estrella
polar para no perder el norte y
desorientando la estrella polar está a
500 años luz de distancia a la vuelta a
la vuelta a la tierra para nosotros
habrían pasado solo 10 años pero en la
tierra el calendario de las casas
marcaría las hojas del año 3000 mejor no
pensamos sobre lo que nos podíamos
encontrar
einstein de esta manera abre de par en
par las puertas del tiempo a partir de
este momento solamente es cuestión
alcanzar esas realidades los viajes al
futuro son perfectamente posibles el
paralelismo con héctor ya hemos contado
del espacio es total pero este no es un
punto de llegada su teoría de la
actividad especial sino por el contrario
un punto de partida y diez años después
de algo los esfuerzos elabora la teoría
de la relatividad general en la cual
como conclusión dos funciones
absolutamente sorprendentes las masas
deforman el espacio lo kullman el
espacio alrededor y además dilatan
también el tiempo
y lo más sorprendente aún es que estas
dos ideas tan extrañas se comprobaron
experimentalmente muy poco tiempo de ser
denunciadas
dos teorías pero actividad especial de
actividad general dos ecuaciones en la
primera la ecuación más conocida más
popular de la física si alguien la
olvida que no tenga problemas en
cualquier camiseta que encuentre por ahí
paseando en el paseo marítimo la
encontrará para recordar se la pone en
nuestras manos una cantidad ingente de
energía la segunda ecuación por contra
es una ecuación otra la extraña poco
intuitiva se puede tener con ella la
misma impresión que cuando contemplamos
una pintura abstracta que no entendemos
pero no es necesario lo que hay que
saber que en esa igualdad en los dos
términos de igualdad están la
distribución de masas y energía calle en
el universo y la curvatura que producen
a su alrededor es como una especie de
chistera de la cual salen auténticas
maravillas en esa ecuación están los
agujeros negros en esa ecuación está el
big-bang en esa ecuación está la
expansión del universo ahí están las
ondas gravitacionales y otras muchas en
esa ecuación veinte años después de
anunciarla albert eisntein buscando a
uno
de la misma encuentra que es posible
teóricamente que en algún rincón del
universo la deformación del
espacio-tiempo haya sido tal que se
puedan encontrar atajos entre dos puntos
y comunicarse entre ellos de forma que
su comunicación llegue antes que un rayo
de luz de esta manera y con esta
suposición se abren también la
posibilidad de los viajes al pasado
la imaginación
es poderosa y
la especulación científica la
especulación aquí el sentido más noble
de la palabra ha sido fértil con la idea
de los viajes en el tiempo cuenta
kip thorne
premio nobel de física en el año 2017
justamente por haber descubierto otra
suposición de la relatividad general las
ondas gravitacionales cuenta escriptor
que en el verano del año 85 recibe la
llamada telefónica de carl sagan de su
amigo cannes haga que le dice que está
escribiendo una novela sobre la
posibilidad de un encuentro humano con
extraterrestres y necesita asesoramiento
científico kimpton es el mayor experto
mundial en agujeros negro quitó le
responde al poco tiempo y le dice
la única posibilidad que tiene hacer ese
viaje planteado es utilizar esos túneles
espacio temporal que había previsto
albert eisntein en el año 1935
la novela es llevada al cine y en
contacto los deportes se convierte en la
primera persona que viaja a través de un
agujero de gusano
pero no acaba aquí la relación de
kriptón con la divulgación de los viajes
en el tiempo en el año 2014 es el asesor
científico de una película bien conocida
interestelar quizás y probablemente la
mejor o el mejor esfuerzo que se haya
realizado sobre la divulgación de la
teoría de la relatividad general que
explora los distintos procedimientos de
gestión temporal a través de fuera en
negro y explora el ir y venir por los
agujeros de gusano realmente estos
serían considerados como una auténtica
máquina del tiempo que se construirá
probablemente después de que pasen unas
situaciones futuras muy muy avanzadas
pero la física actual es muy escéptica
respecto a los viajes en el tiempo
incluso stephen hawking negó la
posibilidad de que se podrían construir
alguna vez máquina del tiempo no
obstante es bueno repasar un poco la
historia somos viajeros cómodos en el
espacio en cualquiera de sus relaciones
pero en el tiempo estamos muy limitados
ya dijimos a una velocidad muy concreta
de un segundo cada segundo pero la
posibilidad de que esta velocidad se vea
alterada se sustenta en el hecho de que
mucho es imposible que en su día se
plantearon bien fundamentado hoy han
dejado de serlo
en 1870 a gusto con el padre del
positivismo científico llegó a afirmar
que sería imposible que nunca
conociéramos de qué están hechas las
estrellas muy pocos años después las
nuevas técnicas espectroscópicas nos
dicen no solamente de que están hechas
sino cuál es su composición centesimal
en 1.195 al tiempo que se escribe la
máquina del tiempo por hg wells
los kelvin dice y pronostica que nunca
se podrán construir máquinas voladoras
más pesadas que el aire en 1903 los
hermanos wright consiguen elevar el
vuelo es una lista que podríamos ampliar
de imposible realizado
y ellos nos lleva a pensar si no es
posible o si podemos afirmar
rotundamente
que no se pueden encontrar agujeros de
usar en el exterior que no se pueden
hacer viaje en el tiempo
no será que la película de interestelar
pueda ser equivalente en los viajes
temporales a lo que fue en su día de la
tienda de los viajes en el tiempo si
alguien dado el tema que estamos
hablando ha tenido la curiosidad de
contar las veces que pronunciando la
palabra tiempo habrá contado 34
la pronunciaría dos veces más para que
sean 36 que es la edad que tenía albert
einstein cuando denunció la teoría
general de la relatividad
nos hace falta la tecnología para
alcanzar esos errores velocidad pero ese
es el problema nuestro combustible
hoy pequeño tímido están estudiándose
con fuentes poderosas de energía
la secuencia se podrá repetir los sueños
inicialmente adquirieron viabilidad
pintando los escribiéndolo filmando los
pero la ciencia y la tecnología a veces
lo hacen posible
miramos al pasado y aprendemos de él y
el futuro nos espera y después de todo
en conclusión solamente puedo decir que
los viajes en el tiempo son cuestión de
tiempo muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]